نحن في طريقنا إلى التعافي في
معركتنا ضد حالات الطمع ، فقد انخفضت
بنسبة 35 بالمائة تقريبًا عن الشهر الماضي
، وانخفض الاستشفاء بنسبة 30 بالمائة تقريبًا
في الشهر وانخفضت الوفيات بنسبة 10
بالمائة تقريبًا عن الأسبوع الماضي ، لذا
سأناقش الآن مع  كبير المراسلين الطبيين في
CNN الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا
مؤلف الكتاب الجديد دروس الحرب العالمية ج
من جائحة covet 19
وكيفية الاستعداد للوباء التالي
دكتور غوبتا ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك واستمع ، آمل
ألا أكون متقدمًا على نفسي عندما  قال إننا
في طريقنا إلى التعافي ، لذا فقد كان صيفًا قاسياً
لأننا نعرف بعض أجزاء
البلاد على الجبهة السرية ،
لكن حالات الوفيات في المستشفيات الآن
تتجه جميعًا إلى الأسفل وهي نهاية هذا
الوباء في الأفق أو
لا أعرف ماذا  حول الإجازات القادمة ،
أعتقد أنه قد يكون في الأفق وأنت
تعلم أنني كنت حذرًا جدًا وأنت
تعلم وأعتقد أننا يجب أن نكون
متواضعين هنا ولكن علينا أيضًا أن ننظر إلى
خطوط الاتجاه الإيجابية ونقرأ
عنها وماذا  أنا ما كنت أفعله
ر  خلال هذا الوباء يحاول أن ينظر إلى ما يحدث هنا ما يحدث في جميع أنحاء العالم ، ما حدث تاريخيًا وأنت على حق ، أعني أن الناس يقولون إن الطقس سيصبح أكثر برودة وجفافًا وهذا هو الوقت الذي ترغب فيه هذه الفيروسات التنفسية في الانتشار إلى تلك النقطة دعنا أريكم ما حدث في عام 2009 ، لكن ما تراه في تلك المرحلة هو أن هناك زيادة في أن تلك الزيادة الكبيرة في الذروة الثانية هي الآن في أكتوبر من عام 2009 ، ثم تنخفض الأرقام كما نراها الآن وتبقى هذا ما حدث في تلك المرحلة إذا عدت إلى الوراء أكثر من 100 عام إلى جائحة الإنفلونزا عام 1918 عام 1919 مرة أخرى أكبر موجة للوباء بأكمله ، كانت هناك ثلاث أو أربع موجات مختلفة هناك ، لكن أكبر موجة كانت مرة أخرى الآن و ثم نزل ثم حصل على زيادة طفيفة مرة أخرى أه في ربيع العام التالي ولكن في الغالب كان هذا أسوأ ما في كلتا الأوبئة السابقة
أعتقد أن جزءًا منه هو
تطعيم الأشخاص وجزء منه أيضًا
لأنه فيروس
معدي تعرض له الكثير من الأشخاص
وطوروا بعض
المناعة الطبيعية لا نعرف كم من الوقت
تلك المناعة الطبيعية  تدوم
وستكون علامة استفهام كبيرة
من حيث الارتفاعات المستقبلية ولكن الآن كما
أشرت فإن جميع خطوط الاتجاه تبدو
مواتية جدًا